dear fellow scholars and this is two
minute papers with dr karo jonai fajir
today we are going to have a look at
google's new ai and find out whether it
is as smart as a human at least in some
test subjects
not so long ago deepmind published an ai
technique and its knowledge in the area
of humanities social sciences and
medicine was fantastic but at
mathematics of all things not so much
interestingly it also thought that it is
a genius and then amusingly it got quite
confused by very simple questions
look at that
do geniuses mess up this multiplication
i think not and that is a bit of a
problem
after all if the genius or non-genius
ais are too unreliable we ask them
something and might have no idea whether
their solutions are correct or not
so our question today is can we improve
the consistency of these ais well let's
have a look at google's new technique
and put it to the real test and i mean
it yes it is going to write a math test
and so much more today and we will see
how it performs
is it as smart as a human
can that really be
we will find out today together
and it turns out it has five amazing
properties that i found really
surprising here goes
one it can solve math problems reliably
and sometimes even in surprising ways
look here it solved the problem in a way
that is not only correct but is
different from the typical reference
solution and the surprises don't stop
there this one can even deal with
questions that include drawings which is
stunning
two a proper ai today has to be
relatively general and this means that
it shouldn't only be good at math it
should be good at other subjects too
and its solutions to these physics
questions are not only correct but clear
crisp and beautiful at the same time
i absolutely love it
so yes it can do not only math but
physics too
but three i hope you know what's coming
oh yes physics and math are not the only
two subjects it can deal with the
generality does not stop there this ai
is a true polymath as we can ask it
about excretory organs in biology or
even electrical engineering chemistry
astronomy and hold on to your papers
because it even knows some machine
learning
yes a machine that learns about itself
how cool is that what a time to be alive
four it significantly outperforms
previous techniques provided that we use
the larger ai model here is a beautiful
example where we can prompt it with a
question and the smaller model fails
i wonder if the larger more capable
version of it would be able to get this
right
does it
yes
so good and
five here you see an example question
from the 2022 poland's national math
exam and now we are finally at the point
where we can ask the question is it as
smart as a human
well if you have been holding on to your
paper so far now squeeze that paper
because the answer is yes
kind of it not only solved this question
correctly but adding everything up it
scored above the national average what's
more it can even solve some undergrad
math problems straight from mit
so yes at least on this particular test
it is at the very least as smart as a
human
i am truly out of words
this means that the consistency of these
solutions is finally at a point where we
could use this as an ai science
assistant a junior assistant who messes
up from time to time mind you but an
assistant nonetheless
what a time to be alive interestingly if
we look under the hood we see that it
works by generating many candidate
solutions and starts a vote between
these solutions and the ones with the
most votes end up being the solutions
that you've seen throughout this video
now not even this technique is perfect
you see some failure cases here but once
again this is so much improvement just
one paper down the line i wonder what
happens if we apply the first law of
papers which says that research is a
process do not look at where we are
look at where we will be two more papers
down the line so what do you think these
will be capable of one more paper down
the line does this get your mind going
let me know in the comments below this
video has been supported by weights and
biases check out the recent offering
fully connected a place where they bring
machine learning practitioners together
to share and discuss their ideas
learn from industry leaders and even
collaborate on projects together you see
i get messages from you fellow scholars
telling me that you have been inspired
by the series but don't really know
where to start
and here it is fully connected is a
great way to learn about the
fundamentals how to reproduce
experiments get your papers accepted to
a conference and more make sure to visit
them through wnb dot me
papers or just click the link in the
video description our thanks to weights
and biases for their long-standing
support and for helping us make better
videos for you thanks for watching and
for your generous support and i'll see
you next time